oh she knows that sound
like I think she probably he probably
follows other people and he's like I'm
trying to mess with her I'm back home
baby oh yeah
oh what are you gonna do look at the
crown look at the crown oh he's not
scared he's like I'll walk through it
he's like Pierce me I dare you won't
take it yeah add to the chair
oh baby oh she likes oh
[Applause]
you guys welcome back to the new rock
stars House of the Dragon uh put away
the bloody Conquest this week in favor
of more Amorous ones leaving us
wondering if Rainer will spill the tea
or drink it
she's gonna throw that [ __ ] no she's not
she's gonna drink it she has to drink it
she has sex with Kristen gold we'll get
into it we'll get into it you guys this
is a big question presents talking
dragons our weekly fantasy after show
I'm Jessica Clemons and I'm here with
Brandon Barrick hello I was so glad to
have you back Jessica I know I'm sad I
missed episode three but episode four is
the best episode I mean this was quite
an episode it was so okay so it was so
good it had four major things that
happened in it where I'm like yeah a lot
of major stuff a lot of kind of
answering some questions from the book
that we're messed up to interpretation
uh a lot of mysterious thing if you
watched it out there with your parents
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
uh this was an interesting one but let's
get into episode four king of the narrow
sea we'll do a quick recap and then
we'll get into some of our big questions
for the week uh another year has passed
in Westeros my how the time flies
rhaenyra has been on a tour of the
continent interviewing suitors while
still wearing the Valerie Aryan steel
necklace that her uncle gave her she's
like playing with it that's the first
thing we see in this episode she starts
out she's at the Baratheon seat in
Storm's end watching the blackwoods and
the Brackins duel it out they have like
a long history uh the brackets betrayed
The black woods it was like a whole
island and young Lucas Blackwood guts
his rival it's just so good to see this
little kid get his revenge I just love
the idea that the guy's like craving and
he's like let's go yeah let's go you say
craving to me you say craving to me and
uh you know Rainier is like I've had
enough let's get out of here she heads
back to King Landing a little early on
the tour which really pisses off her dad
and Allison because they worked very
hard with this tour it was messy it was
messy and also she's touching that
necklace clearly she has other people I
know but like the first guy we see this
episode is this old man who saw her
great grandmother that's how old was she
gorgeous
consists such things to her great
granddaughter let's find out uh yeah
let's get let's get her some suitable
suitors
please but someone else is coming back
to the red keep as well it's Prince
Damon Targaryen arriving unannounced uh
and now being called King of the narrow
sea complete with a makeshift wooden
crown with a little gold little Jewels
tied to it very cute uh everyone is very
tense about what's going to happen but
Damon kneels and pledges his loyalty
offering viserys the crab feeder's
hammer and telling him to add it to the
chair what a line my guy so good it was
the hottest thing he's ever done but
also it was just like such a power play
of like I did it because you couldn't
yeah he did tell me we're coming no one
knows what he's gonna do he comes in
wearing a crown like very intense this
short hair short hair looking nice
looking nice looking nice it was such a
power play but I still think when we'll
talk about at the end he's not he didn't
get the high well yeah he didn't get The
High Ground so yeah he comes back it
seems like everything's okay now uh
viserys and Damon seem to be good Bros
again chumming it up even Rainier and
Allison Bond over the fact that they
feel trapped by their position though
it's clear that Allison feels her burden
is heavier uh she doesn't get to choose
her spouse and is now forced to take
care of multiple children and a husband
who is falling apart of the seams uh and
while she might care for him she might
actually love viserys I don't know she
doesn't get a say and when the love
making happens I also think it's just
genuinely like she's like oh I enjoy
talking to this person right it's great
this is my best friend's dad it's my
best friend's dad ruined her
relationship I mean she said she doesn't
have a lot of friends now a lot of shots
of her this episode being trapped in the
castle kind of looking out the window
taking care of the baby taking care of
her husband who's like drunk all the
time and and disgusting uh being forced
to have sex with him late at night
looking at Rats on the even in the in
the Majesty of King's Landing there's
like a rat crawling around there's been
a lot of shots of rats in this episode
and I was like lots of rats lots of rats
uh Damon leaves a loot box for an era to
find including some peasants clothes
that smell really bad and a map to help
sneak out of the castle and King's
Landing they take in a show from a bunch
of Mummers that shows rhaenera might not
be the small folks choices Heir which I
love that that shot of her being like
Boo Boo heresy
you're really pretty and not dirty to be
walking around the rest of us like I
wouldn't know immediately or up to
something yeah yeah um her sneaking out
was also Chef that was that was very uh
I solemnly swear that I'm up to no good
right yeah the red keep you know was
built uh was finished under Omega Mega
or the Conqueror right and he purposely
built all these secret passageways
inside of the Red Cube there's all these
little secret tunnels and stuff and then
he got all the builders together it was
like great job guys you made me a great
castle with all these secret passageways
here's a big dinner and then the next
day he killed them yep yep so a lot of
people don't know about the secrets that
part of the book is very fun yeah yeah
yeah and him kind of and Damon kind of
showing right near like hey you can
sneak out of here there's all these
little there's one in your room you
didn't even know about I didn't even
know about it yeah yeah that also we'll
probably get into it but when she comes
back and so Crystal is like how did you
win
either either way you guys is when it
starts getting crazy yeah they hit up
some bars Rainer plays a little Aladdin
and then they take a trip to a brothel
via Damon's lead yeah yeah touchy touchy
as reneres led into this den of sin and
has shown that some people get down
however they want Damon makes his
intentions for his niece known and very
clear and renera goes from being nervous
to taking control and Damon experiences
some of the impotence we saw in episode
one with uh
yeah yes as soon as like the woman is
into it he's like not into it I like
that idea in that theory but I also like
I think he genuinely does love her he's
just so evil he doesn't know how to show
it yeah it's hard to tell what causes
that moment I mean bangs the wall and
ditches her there which is so if he
really loves her that's messed up uh but
it's also brought up earlier in the
episode too that you know he hasn't been
able to uh make an error with his wife
who he calls the bronze [ __ ] what what
a name uh yeah he's so that is true I
forgot about that part and you might be
all around impotent for everyone I think
that's true and that's a good idea let's
hold on to that let's note that uh the
reasons for it could be plenty but
whatever the case he ditches or an era
after making sure she was spotted by
some of the patrons yeah yeah he pulls
her hat off right when they come in
everyone you know even though they're
getting down they're like oh I think I
know who that girl is and they know who
Damon is yeah uh so yeah also you know
yeah you know them by their hair yeah
like oh yeah so hair stands out to rip
off her beanie is like oh yeah it's
clearly a Target area and clearly uh
after making her way back to the red
keep Ramiro decides to take matters into
her own hands and have her way with sir
Kristen Cole Eva ever by her side or
doorway you know he's been there those
last few episodes always taken care of
her when she's hit on the ship he's like
oh are you okay you know with the pig he
was like we should go yeah but yeah yeah
he's always taking care of her uh even
though it's like he's he's very clearly
into her it's it's made obvious that he
doesn't want this event to get in the
way of his position on the King's Garden
he's got everything to lose here I mean
who wouldn't want a night with the
princess but like very dangerous for him
to be messing around with this and the
next day is very much like I don't want
to play this game anymore uh don't call
me over like uh I love to see when he's
like leading her into like viserys's
room but like look on his face as he
like opens the door for her through the
helmet he's like uh you better keep your
mouth shut okay
but news of raynera and Damon's night on
the town has made its way to Otto
Hightower via massaria who's now known
as the White Worm she wears white she
she gets into everyone's Secrets uh Otto
tries to cash in on the gossip but
viserys is not so pleased to hear that
his daughter might have been coupling uh
with his brother I love the lion read
that re-siphons gives here where he's
like well must I say it
he's gonna make my grandson the king I'm
like uh while he's while he's dishing
this gossip Alice said here's two and
she confronts Rainier but Rainier is
steadfast that she didn't have sex last
night with her Uncle that's what she
says she's like I didn't have sex with
my uncle uh and uh and right because
Allison is is upset that her maidenhood
would be ruined by her having sex before
marriage uh and that would ruin her
marrying prospects again Allison and
viserys worked very hard uh to get uh
this kind of tour put together of
suitors and I gotta find a good Suiter
for her you'll also notice uh that
rhaenyra is wearing a new necklace uh
now uh I I do love this scene too where
they kind of switch positions like At
first Allison has The High Ground during
this argument and then Ramirez takes The
High Ground very very very good
directing in this episode uh yeah fun to
see like the new necklace like I am so
over my uncle I hate him what are you
talking about what a jerk what a jerk
what a jerk what a jerk I mean yeah he's
a jerk so viseria's uh confronts Damon
over the matter Damon doesn't deny
anything literally he does not deny a
single thing he says yeah I took her in
there what about it and also asking
series to give renera to him as his wife
Damon says piss off and go back to your
lawful wife and never come back and for
real this time he literally is like I
don't care I don't want to see you again
don't have sex with my daughter uh
Allison tells the series that Damon is
lying and renere is telling the truth
viserys doesn't know how who to believe
and tells his daughter that she's got a
merry laner Valerian who was writing
them writing yeah he was writing sea
smoke he's a cordless valerian's son
honestly hot as hell to clean up his
perception problem in the Kingdom she
agrees but only if only is viserys
removes Otto as hand of the king he does
it but not before sending his daughter a
little Moon tea to make sure everything
is taken care of wink wink yeah we're
left at the end of the episode wondering
if she's gonna drink this Moon the the
maester is he literally knows everything
going on yeah that's like the big kind
of overarching theory with Game of
Thrones and House of the Dragon is that
like beneath that all the maesters are
working seat the targaryens so they're
very happy to uh make sure that no more
are born you know oh you want a little
Moon tea happy to brew that out he's
like oh yeah also uh I don't trust
anything the maesters bring me 100 uh
it's brought up several times in this
episode how rainy you know what happened
to Rainier's mom and that makes her
fearful of childbirth and makes her
fearful of being forced to have these
heirs uh but at the same time it's like
do I trust anything that the maesters
are bringing me I don't know I don't
know this could just kill me uh well
we'll get into all that uh here on
talking dragons but before we do be sure
to grab our limited edition latest
Obsession shirt Ashton ruin inspired by
house of the Dragon uh and all the blood
and guts on that show uh this show won't
be available for long it'll be uh Gone
faster than uh a baby from the Moon
Brandon Barrick but make sure you pick
it up it's limited edition it's a great
way to support the channel and when you
purchase this shirt you unlock an
opportunity to get a custom shout out
that'll appear right here on talking
dragons and we may even shout it out
here on the show uh like this one from
Leroy B who said absolutely love new
rock stars keep killing it we'll do our
best we we love to kill it uh also we
got a shout out from Keith B who said
bore on the floor uh for my succession
folks out there on the floor the hot dog
they're on the ground and all the people
have to like wait are you talking about
letting the rich people have to get on
the floor they make up a game and they
call it boar on the floor no that
episode maybe be like I know rich people
are crazy but that's that is crazy uh
and this show has shown us that
throughout time rich people have been
here it's always been crazy
dethroned them uh yeah check out that
shirt pick it up newrockstarsmerch.com
uh okay so there were a lot of schemes
and Whispers going on this week Jessica
uh behind all the tawdry Affairs
happening uh we know the Game of Thrones
is a dangerous one but who poses the
greatest danger now It All Leads us to
our big question this week who's the
bigger threat to viserys here okay so we
have Damon on one hand and we have Otto
on the other okay they both have their
weird little plans to get power in the
Kingdom uh and this week it seemed like
viserys was finally aware of Auto
schemes I want to talk about Auto first
okay
when he confronts Otto he brings up this
kind of story this five days story right
about how his dad was made the hand of
the king and then suddenly died from a
bloated belly five days later and then
Otto comes in and now he's served his
hand for two kings right uh he's this
long-serving hand he got his daughter
Allison in there and it seems like
vasera says now like this episode he's
hyper aware of everyone making moves
again right and he's like get out of
here do you think
Otto worked to kill viserys's father he
seemed quite shocked by that but he also
plays that kind of shocked face a lot I
I don't know it's it's hard because I
think I think he genuinely is like my
job my loyalty my loyalty to the throne
because now my family's involved with
the throne like directly his grandson is
yeah he's got some blood so I don't but
I think everyone's always fighting to be
a part of the throne that's why I'm like
I could see him trying to kill someone
to get in but I think he genuinely is a
good hand and maybe that's me believing
Auto Hightower as an actor well he does
bring up a good point he's like if he's
like your majesty I got this news I had
to tell it to you right I have to share
this news with you now he's working to
get this news he's getting he's making
sure Rainier is spied on or at least he
has a look at at this brothel where he
knows Damon's gonna show up right and
that kind of leads into like Damon's
role in all this the last time Damon was
at this brothel and uh mentioned the air
for a day yeah that or or maybe didn't
we didn't see him say the words but he
him at the brothel making a speech made
its way back to Otto Auto shared it with
the series that led to the all the kind
of problems in episode one uh for Damon
right do you think he he purposely
brings rhemara there he removes her her
hat so that everyone recognizes her did
he know that this was going to make its
way back to Otto 100 100 absolutely yeah
absolutely because I think he knows Otto
is the one that outed him for the king
of the day thing so he was like he's
gonna get to him that's gonna get to him
or it's just gonna get to him somehow
but I think he knew it was gonna be Otto
specifically
um but that is also a good thing to note
is that it's just
it was it not warranted what Otto did
because I'm like I understand having a
spy on Damon because Damon's messing up
all the time and you need to tell the
king like hey this person's messing up
isn't unwarranted to have him follow the
princess and be like
she's probably going to do something
well if your reason though for following
the princess is to get her removed as
Heir and get your your uh grandson put
in his air yeah that's that's the tricky
part right like and as I I do respect
viserys here kind of sticking up for his
daughter when Otto comes in that's true
initially and Otto's like your daughter
was spotted at like a pillow house and
viserys was like and your point is like
you know he's like when I was this age
I'm allowed to go around and do whatever
I want and she brings renera brings this
up too like if I was a male I could have
as many bastards as I wanted but because
I'm a female I had to keep my maidenhood
until I get married for power for
political purposes even though the
series is letting her choose an error or
choose a Suitor uh all these suitors
suck she's big like you can choose from
my pool yeah which is and I don't know I
don't know if she's seen a picture of
Leonor recently or a drawing of him
Elena was fine well that's what I mean
because as soon as like viserys is like
you got to marry Leno she's like fine
great uh he's not a bad looking dude
he's got it he can ride the dragon yeah
and I I would think that he would have
started riding dragons at a young age
maybe when the last when he was in
episode one and he's still kind of young
oh yeah uh during the tournament I don't
know if he was Dragon riding then or not
not really no uh he might he was
definitely like raised with sea smoke so
he might have ridden him at that point
but she in the back of her mind she's
probably her or she's probably at least
heard by this point that lane nor is a
dragon rider so she's like yeah I'll
marry this guy oh so this person's like
of a just not going to be like a child
it's not gonna be a child
it's a good it's a it's her cousin
freaking Lannister but she was ready to
jump her uncle's bones so I don't think
a cousin should bother her that much you
know I I don't want to draw distinct her
uncle gets her and understand I don't
like that I'm shipping this incest right
it makes he's the only person that
actually talks to her as an adult I will
say this episode you know there's a lot
of heavy things to kind of wrap your
mind around when it comes to sex and
power uh and Grooming
you know Damon's an older guy who's been
kind of grooming his niece this way his
entire time he's the only one he's the
only one in the family like really
showing her affection like her dad has
been absent like he's the one that's
kind of raced her and it's very
manipulative him to take her out of like
her comfort zone put her in this
position he's using her he is using her
and then and but in a way she kind of
uses sir Christian Cole because he's a
man who can't make he can't really say
no to her he could he could say no to
her but that would cost him his job him
copulating with her could cost him his
job and his life like there's a lot of
Dangerous Power plays going on here yeah
uh and and through it all like Allison
is trapped as well like she's forced uh
to have sex with the king oh my God what
I like about this episode is this is the
episode where we're finally you don't we
can feel bad for Rainer but we're now
seeing her yeah and I think like when
Allison was like at least you get to
choose things yeah I don't get to choose
and she's like and then when she goes
and sees the town play and she's like
they don't they don't know they don't
know and it doesn't matter and it's like
well you're gonna be ruling them so you
should care what she said something like
what they want is of no consequence to
me and like that's kind of true like
they don't get a say in it but that's
also you want to be feared or loved and
it's like if you're feared they're gonna
just not be with you well they're gonna
take it over this is you know this is a
time of Peace in the realm yeah she
doesn't know what happened like
Generations ago when the the people kind
of turned against uh uh uh uh a man a
Targaryen who married his sister right
like that drove the people crazy they
were like absolutely not and they kind
of overthrew it through their Rebellion
it kind of caused so did enough chaos in
the Kingdom that maegor was able to take
over exactly and they were like well
this guy is terrible but at least he's
not married to his sister though then he
married a bunch of his family so you
know it happens it happens
but yeah I think it is interesting I I
don't know what Otto's next move is
going to be he's not gonna he's not
gonna team up with Damon no he doesn't
want us to make sure if you saw the kind
of like what's coming up next episode
you see that like you know we know
viserys is not long for this world he's
getting sicker by the day by the year as
they jump through uh he's he you know we
see in the next episode this was in the
preview clip he tells his daughter like
yo get my grandson ready for the The
Throne yeah like that's his main thing
like whatever happens
Otto wants to kind of secure the
hightower's position because again he's
the second son his brother gets to be
the Lord uh down in Old Town and he's
just kind of like I've got to do
something here I've got to make sure
that my position is maintained yes so
well what other families do we have we
have
um because he's probably gonna team up
with another family it's not gonna be
the valerians right he doesn't like well
yeah he was the one that was he's the
one who's been pitched Otto's been
pitching again it's like uh marry your
daughter to aegon uh uh let's let's
forget someone else here and that's his
problem he's only looking out for his
family so when it comes to teams and
just having someone on his side he
doesn't have anyone else his son is is
his son still alive after getting
knocked on his ass yeah yeah his son
lost that tournament but he's still
alive he got embarrassing and
embarrassing and when you were married
that was years ago at this
Point uh I mean I I really think you
know marrying a rhaenyra and to to
Leonard Valerian it's it's a smart move
it is a good power play and viserys
brings up you know we'll have like we'll
run the skies with the dragons we'll run
the Seas with the ships they got a lot
of money it's gonna be great for us
right uh and it is a smart move to
combine these two let's have these two
dragon Riders kind of set up for success
in the kingdom and I'm sure Corliss is
going to be very happy to hear this do
you think Corliss is going to come back
to the council now no because he left us
the master of ships do you think he'll
come back
maybe he will now because they're
getting it's like okay he didn't marry
my daughter but she she's gonna still be
in our family directly I think he will
come back but the biggest trouble will
be like are you gonna pass on the title
to that damn high tower son are you
ready well what's interesting in the
meeting the small council meeting a lot
of the members referred to Corliss as
the sea snake they wouldn't say his name
which I thought was very interesting uh
I it would be interesting if like
Corliss came back to be the hand even
though I think the stairs would never do
that yeah but it would be it would be
smart to keep him close yeah to make to
force him to be in King's Landing would
be very smart I don't think he will but
I think I think that would be the next
smart move he's getting crazy and sicker
like he's just and drunker so I I could
see him he's making bad decisions which
is bringing Corliss that close
um it's definitely not gonna be Damon uh
it could be the bigger guy that's not a
Baratheon um who's the guy that strong
Lionel strong I think so it could be him
yeah he loves him we saw his sun again
break bones break bones was the gold
cloak that kind of recognized rhaenyra
in the streets which I wondered if Damon
had kind of set that up a little bit uh
oh you think he orchestrated every piece
I think Damon orchestrated every little
part of that trip to King's Landing uh
even having break bones out there
because he he could trust break bones I
don't know break bones I think is really
hot on rhaenyra too in the books he's a
potential Suitor for her even though
Lionel strong and this is like no don't
worry about my sons they don't need to
be uh married to your daughter but like
he was and he was the one in episode
three uh when Rainier comes back with
the boar he's like oh yeah good job this
girl's blood on your face it's hot as
hell I like this girl so I think what he
recognizes her in the street it is very
funny uh I I did get a kick out of that
I didn't love it but yeah I in the books
as well like the thing that's very
different uh to what's been portrayed on
the show in the books it takes Damon
longer to come back to King's Landing
he's gone for a few years after the crab
feeder dies uh and he also stays longer
in King's Landing and for a little bit
is on the High Council or the small
council with the King uh so it's
interesting that he's kind of in the
city he tries to work his little plan
and he's gone again yeah I don't know if
he actually wanted do you think he
really wants to marry Ramirez or do you
think it's just to get his brother's
attention I think he still has a motive
he will always have a motive but I think
that motive which is this is such a like
a cartoony fairy tale way of saying it
but I think he does love her he's like
she is the only person in the family
that respected me yeah I respected her
we always had each other that scene on
the first episode where they had to like
set the baby and the mom on fire when
they died he was the one that was like
you got it yeah he was the only one
comforting her like I thought it was
interesting too right after you know
when they're kind of partying in the
garden and uh you know viser says
something like they're kind of arguing
like no you were mom's favorite no Bubba
you were the favorite it's interesting
because Rainier is clearly not her
father's favorite yeah but he wants a
son even when there wasn't a son to be
had she wasn't the favorite uh and I
think they they bond on that right
they're the like not the favorite
they're the outcasts a little bit away I
think that was in the second episode
that I really just want to see come so
many times when Corliss was talking to
uh Damon and he was like we're the
seconds yeah we're the second borns they
treat us like [ __ ] but we're better than
them even though Corliss is kind of
lying man he's not really the same he
isn't but like I think he just just
sucks but it's I do want I'm like yeah
you guys need to link up all the second
forms be evil together right right be it
just get you a little evil machinations
and same with uh renera she's not the
second but they're gonna Treat Her Like
She's the third yeah I know she's
featured her way down on the list uh I
do like when viserys says like you know
they have the blood of the dragons in
them you know their their ornery
basically they're ready to fight all the
time yes but at the end of the episode
we see his blood of the Dragon come out
when he holds the knife to his brother's
throat and he's like get out of here go
back to your bronze [ __ ] I don't care
what you do get out of here you gotta
get out of here I'm tired of you even
though he wanted so bad to have it he
was so happy to have this brother back
he's gonna come back he's going to come
well I think that's I think the next
time Damon comes back uh there's gonna
be no uh trick to it he's going to be
very clear with his intentions when he
comes Hightower uh was right and they
should have killed him at the start they
should have killed Damon immediately he
is because you don't have that soft spot
for his brother and I'm like your
brother is literally chaos yeah he is I
mean literally but Sarah says you are
the pl you're a plague basically as he's
riddled with some sort of physical
plague he calls his brother the plague
you know it's sad uh yeah I don't I
don't trust either Otto or Damon they've
all got plans up their sleep they don't
but at least Damon's bad and knows he's
bad
yeah at least he cut his hair
yeah and he clearly only cares about
weird sex
some people they have they only have a
certain way they can get off and they
got it oh the weird part in that it's in
a
group
do what you got to do I mean that's what
this show is really about that I like is
that like the Shades of Gray of everyone
yeah you're not 100 good or 100 bad
there's a little bit of mix in there
even Rainier like the character I think
they're presenting to us as the main
protagonist of the show she's got her
own Shades of Gray oh since the first
episode Which Game of Thrones did very
well they make they the characters are
so good and so well written that it's
like you you're choosing signs
immediately and you're like yeah this
guy sucks like the king I was
immediately like is sucky he is
literally bad he's a horrible King we
should have thrown him so I love that
it's like this episode was really
nailing in like oh yeah renera is a
princess and acts like a princess and
also doesn't recognize that she's worth
a lot right and she's making it everyone
else's problem yeah and she she is very
smart but then she makes dumb moves she
makes dumb moves she's you know she's
raised inside of this Castle she doesn't
know what it's like out there on the
streets yeah a very Aladdin move but
also I'm not trying to be that pretty
person that's like well that's right if
it's not break bones that catches her
and doesn't recognize her yeah another
gold cloak we've seen how they act yeah
it might have been really like sliced
their hands up or something
that we're not there uh but before we
get to more of our big questions on this
episode we want to thank a couple of our
sponsors this week uh
our first one being Masterworks you know
inflation has driven up the cost of
everything this year and not all of us
are living it up like the Lannisters
with tons of gold uh but what if you
want to increase the the gold and your
own coffers do you have a financial plan
for that I certainly don't but some very
uh smart people out there do and some of
those people are following guidance from
places like Bank of America who says
that real assets like Contemporary Art
can help lessen the plane of inflation I
know art is unfamiliar but the last time
inflation was this High contemporary are
appreciated at an average of 33 per year
that's a lot of percentages every year
that's more than gold real estate and
the S P 500 during that same period back
in the day investors would need millions
of dollars to invest in art but those
days aren't over thanks to Masterworks
this platform buys actual paintings not
nfts not those uh these are real
paintings from names like Picasso and
Banksy those are names you've probably
heard of uh and what it does is it takes
those actual paintings and it breaks
them into share shares the painting is
not broken thank goodness but it takes
pieces of those paintings so you're
investing in just a piece of the
painting and you can own some of it this
way you get all the inflation protection
from the art for a fraction of the cost
I'm not the only one who thinks this is
genius over 500 000 people have joined
so far and with inflation still at
record highs so many people are joining
uh that there's a wait list but if you
are hearing my voice or seeing my face
right now that means you have an
opportunity to skip that wait list just
go to
masterworks.art bigquestion that's
that's Masterworks dot art bigquestion
uh and see important regulation A
disclosures at masterworks.com CD that's
masterworks.art big question
we also want to thank backbone what's
holding you back from the ultimate
gaming experience is it the hundreds of
dollars it costs for you to set up or
are you the busy on the go type with
only minutes to spare both both for
Jessica level up your game with backbone
the universal gaming essential that
instantly enhances your gaming
experience on mobile we have one right
here this one's designed for an iPhone
isn't it beautiful they just released
their uh PlayStation edition of their
lovely black uh their beloved backbone
one this is it right here uh the
officially licensed controller for
PlayStation was brought to life in
collaboration with PlayStation design
team the elegant colors materials and
finishes are inspired by the design of
the PS5 dual sense controller all the
way down to the transparent face buttons
and it's visually distinctive floating
appearance simply plug your iPhone into
the backbone and enjoy console quality
controls as you play your console games
via remote play or Cloud streaming
services and the App Store games I never
really like playing a console games on
my phone myself until I tried it out on
the background much easier my big thumbs
on the screen it gets all smudgy I don't
like that it also feels really cool yeah
it feels really cool to be like
I'm an old man uh I'm at least over 25
years old so I didn't grow up playing
mobile games I grew up with a controller
so I like having a controller when I
play games on my phone I was born in
2001 and I love having this she loves
having it and she's younger than me it
just really it makes Mobile gaming so
much uh easier and more precise I really
appreciate it so if you want to check it
out for yourself go go to
playbackbone.com big question right now
to order your backbone for a limited
time and get free that's right free
access to over 350 console games and
perks backbound backbone is now the
official partner of Diablo Immortal not
only is the game specifically optimized
for backbone but you will also receive
ten dollars of in-game perks find your
next adventure at playbackbone.com big
question
sorry I forgot that we have two shows to
talk about so I spent the first half of
this oh that's okay that's okay we got
more to talk about we'll get to rings of
power here in a second but I want to ask
you a couple more questions about uh
this episode of House of the Dragon this
is my next question do you drink the
moon tea okay she's drinking the movie
This is how we leave the episode she's
drinking the movie this is a real
prisoner's dilemma type test right okay
the maester comes in she's like what is
this he's like it's a little tea little
special T I brewed up you got to be very
precise don't worry I was precise let's
hope uh but he says it's from the king
so King so she tells us there is my main
Hood's intact Allison says I believe her
hermanian Hood's attack it's not intact
uh but that doesn't matter as far as the
king knows if he believes his daughter
it is he doesn't believe his daughter
that's fine he was also a young man he
sewed his Wild Oats this is him
basically saying without saying it to
her face like here's the T just drink it
I don't care what you did let's drink
the tea now if you are Rainier in this
situation
in theory you send this tea back right
but this is going to get back to the
king that you don't drink the tea right
uh which is what she should be doing if
she wants to keep up the facade of like
I kept my manhood intact right yeah but
in the back of her mind she's probably
thinking maybe I should drink this tea
because she had a night of passion with
sir Christian Cole we don't have that
know how that night ended yeah we don't
know if he pulled out there you go uh
but even that is not 100 effective right
yeah sure the only 100 effective thing
as my youth pastor would say was
abstinence
did they have the goat skin condoms at
this time they might have but again not
a hundred percent even though our modern
condoms are not 100 so she's probably
thinking I should drink this uh tea
which my wife wanted to call plan t
instead of Plan B okay wait get her get
off the shower get her on this she she
made sure I made sure to give her credit
for that that was a good one so he gives
her the plan T does she drink it so uh I
think maybe you you gotta like drink it
but then fill it up with a different tea
and then give it back to them I hope the
maester's like I didn't this is the same
tea well that's the thing that maester
would know right so maybe like when he
comes back the next day you'll be like
oh I didn't drink this tea give it back
to the maester but as you're giving it
back you like spell it like oops oh and
I smell the teeth he's like that's water
I mean she's got to drink the tea right
the thing is yeah she's got to drink the
tea a b i I know that in the storyline
it's a big deal but I'm also like maybe
it's not maybe she just drinks the tea
just to be like are you happy I didn't
have sex but I still drank my stupid tea
you're stupid Earl Gray yeah so like
it's like uh but I understand that she
is she is a dragon within herself she is
a young girl that's like very upset she
as soon as she fought with her dad she
instead of getting in her car and
driving to limit McDonald's parking lot
like I did she got on that horse and
drove into the middle of the woods yeah
so I'm like yeah she's very defiant and
she she would normally send that back
but it's like just drink it and then
throw that glass against the wall or
some [ __ ] like do do something else
outrageous now we also this Moon team
made me think about we saw Allison drink
some tea uh you think it's the same
thing well I you know the maesters need
to brew it and I think I think it was
implied that Allison was drinking like
kind of a relaxing tea she's had a hard
day taking care of her baby taking care
of I still think it's the poppy the milk
of the puppy a little milk I think she's
like I'm gonna I think she's trying to
chill out but it made me think that like
it's Allison sick of having kids 100 and
it's like I'm gonna drink my own tea
That's Gonna Keep Me
so is this after she had the girl
already been a girl yeah yeah it's been
a year since the last episode so
whatever baby she was very pregnant with
before she definitely happened I think
that was implied that was the baby we
saw her I think this is just that wasn't
aegon she was too yeah I think this is
just mirroring
um just like a like a 40s housewife
she's like I she don't like this life
this life sucks for me my dad like
literally forced me into coupling with
this fun like my best friend's dad yeah
ruined everything I think it's just her
being like this is her form of Quaalude
yeah we see her like looking out the
window and the window is like covered
with bar you know it's like it's in
prison she's in a prison uh where she's
forced to copulate with the King even
whether it's late at night girl I when I
saw that scene I was like act like
you're sleeping
I love Allison and this is a weird uh
this is a weird character to like I
actually I think a lot of us should like
her uh she is working her ass off and if
she betrays anyone rightfully so because
she has been dealing with so much [ __ ]
well and I think I think she poured a
lot into this tour and like actually
trying to find a good mate for her
friend when she's like my friend gets to
choose I'm gonna set up as many options
and for her for Rainier to come back
early and just like screw it all up and
now she finds out she's banging her
uncle in a pillow house she's like
you're ruining everything this is all I
have in my life and you're screwing it
up it's like uh it's it's frustrating
for her because she has no control of
anything and now we're gonna see how he
viserys is gonna start treating her like
[ __ ] when she was talking
um when they were talking to each other
and he's like oh the tapestries and he
was like you're stupid [ __ ] like it was
like no I wasn't see so curious to see
the attempt more tapestries of people
banging all over we can't even show them
on the show if you if you haven't
noticed in the show the tapestries in
the background check them out Allison's
room is full of pornographic tapestries
of men women dragons engaging in all
sorts of fornication it's wild why do we
got these well we couldn't get them the
printer refused to make the tapestries
we wanted we couldn't find the right guy
oh my God but she drank that team she's
drinking that tea and she's got to drink
the tea or else she's gonna be having
sir Christian Cole's baby but if she did
have circus baby and the Valerian baby
they kind of look similar so maybe no
one else I mean a dornish Targaryen mix
would be quite interesting I don't know
as the baby grows up they're like this
is darnish baby this is adornation I
mean they collect those dorms from a
mile away that man's dornish
[Laughter]
one more quick thing uh let's talk about
the pyromancers in the song uh the
pyromancer song in The Blaze oh yeah we
learned a little bit more about the cat
that's probably this episode uh that was
kind of wild when this is when rhaenyra
has led to her Kings to her dad's room
right uh Kristen Cole's like don't say
anything when you're going there okay
she walks in she doesn't see her dad
instead she sees this blade that she's
been told how important it is sitting in
Fire and man my heart sank for a second
I was like what is he about to do to her
I thought he was going to burn her uh
but then he comes out of the Shadows
like don't touch that but we learned a
little bit more about the history of
this thing so this blade came from like
we can trace it back to aegon's Father
uh Amir I think I'm saying that
inappropriately uh uh we don't know
where it came from before that but it
comes from Valeria we know that much
it's Valerian steel obviously it
survives the Doom uh and the pyromancers
kind of put the song into it and the
song was from my blood comes the prince
that was promised and his will be the
Song of Ice and Fire now the prince that
was promised came up at Game of Thrones
uh lady macandro right she was the one
that said that but she was kind of
getting it wrong uh you know and that
leads to a lot of consequences for
people
um but it was interesting to see how
this is where that prophecy comes from
it comes from the blade so at some point
lady missandra hears this uh this uh
Prophecy from someone presumably a
Targaryen at some point because only the
targaryens really have this blade as it
gets passed down then it gets lost at
some point but
um
I thought that was very interesting but
also bringing up the pyromancers
every episode we get a little bit of
like magic mentioned I'm waiting for
that magic to really play into this show
that's what I also locate two things I
think Hightower is going to be coming
with magic but like I think he's going
to team up with someone that we haven't
seen yet that's going to be about magic
a little dark magic and I'm getting so
tired of the series bringing up these
old Tales of like magic and this is
happening he's not staying in the moment
of everything the war that is currently
going on again in the last episode he
said he's a dreamer right yeah he takes
these dreams and these prophecies very
seriously he's always carrying that
blade it's always on him he's going to
cut Damon with him he doesn't watch his
mouth right
it's very important to him and he's just
frustrated that like his daughter who he
chose to be the air he wants her to take
everything seriously especially this I
think he's just he's so paranoid about
the whole thing and it's it's really
distracting him yeah and we know the
hindsight of knowing what comes next
that it is going to come true but not
for a long time and he doesn't need to
stress so bad right now oh it's
irritating me which also Loki is what's
irritating me with Lord of the Rings too
because I'm like we know what happens
it's gonna be so long until it actually
happens but this is what happens to the
targains right like as you get named the
air you get told this thing and how you
react to it is very important yeah and
it's kind of driving viserys crazy it is
that's why he's not being a good King at
all he's becoming he's being a pushover
and his daughter points that he's like
you're a pushover like whoever you talk
to you do what they say and it's like
you're the king don't let Auto Hightower
tell you what to do get his ass out of
here he's trying to please everybody and
I think I think it was when he was
talking to viserys where he was or when
he was starting to Rainer where it was
like
why was it Rainer where he was talking
to someone and was like why would I
start a fight with them
and then like I please them and then I
start a fight with another person right
right if I plea I can't please both of
them and it's like yeah that's the point
you don't have oh it was Allison I was
like okay well then let me give you a
better question is it better that he's
dead or alive yeah you freaking idiot
yeah he's he's a mess he's falling apart
of the seams his fingers or his backs
are disgusting there's rats in the
castle someone's got to do something so
yeah someone couldn't
uh and that's why you know Damon his
proposition is interesting like let me
marry reynyra give her to me which is
you know come on let her have some
agency uh but like he's like let us he
he wants to make the Targaryen strong
again he sees them as weak and this is
one way to do it but viserys is going
the route of mixing them uh with the
valence which is also true is like it's
probably stronger and better for us if
we're not you see how many people hate
that we marry within the family yeah so
let's keep it in the mirror and have
multiple wives they don't like that the
septons don't like that so it's like and
also I get something from this with you
it's just my brother that was a [ __ ]
well speaking of brothers and [ __ ]
let's switch over real fast and do a
little talking Tolkien huh a little
talking
uh so the third episode of rings of
power had dropped uh and then it will
give you a quick recap a gladriel and
Hall brand have been rescued from the
sea and taken to numenor an island
nation with a history of Friendship with
the elves that has withered over time uh
the captain that saved them alendil
seems to have uh seems Keen to help
Galadriel and they I think they shared a
couple looks a couple times uh alendo
his name like means friend of elves he's
from a section of a numenor where they
like were friends with the elf still
because uh our good friends uh brother
yeah ruled that section he chose to be a
human I didn't know if you're half elf
half human at some point you get to pick
why would you not pick elf pick elf all
day well no because everybody hates the
elves I don't I don't know his little
kingdom they were happy with them they
got a cute little
um House of lore a little Library
uh uh though it's clear he's on thin ice
for even bringing the elf to numenor
elenjo is he's got kids of his own to
look out for but he seems he seems Keen
to help Galadriel uh back in the
Southlands a rondir is sent to the orc
Chain Gang where he learns that the Orcs
are using their enslaved workers to look
for something as they kind of tunnel
away and avoid the sun there are other
elves who have been trapped by the Orcs
we saw them in the first episode from
the Watchtower uh but that it's clear
that the Orcs have the upper hand here
right they've yeah they're strong enough
to like they kill one of the elves
pretty easily and also okay well we can
get into it that scene was so good I
loved it but also I was like why that
one I was like what you waited till the
third one gets his drink and then just
go you can't make him move first I I
don't know so the elves that kind of
wait until the right moment when the sun
is strong to make their move but thanks
to a Warg and a few well-shot arrows
their Escape Plan improves pretty useful
uh useless meanwhile Nori's secret is
out and the Brandy foots have been
shunned by the the other hard foots
thanks to the reveal of the tall
stranger this guy is a menace get him at
it
also yeah help me cart
die
he waited till they until Dan's like
almost dead all in all we learned that
Sauron now goes by the name anadar uh so
make sure you get it right and that
looks like where R and deer was being
taken towards the end uh so that that
was this episode of of rings of power uh
I I really like seeing Norman Norman
Newman here uh very beautiful when she
says beautiful she rolls the r she goes
and I was like
either way I like um which I mean I
think we're getting from this is seeing
these Villages that are not Villages
giant towns that are now like scrapped
in Lord of the Rings and it's like this
is how pretty it was at one point and
I'm like oh everyone I know by the time
we get to the Lord of the Rings we knew
a lot of these cities are destroyed this
is where Viggo mortensen's from uh I
don't 100 know is this where Vigo
Morrison's from
dashel
okay Lord of the Rings expert says kind
of I thought this was where he was let
us know in the chat how wrong we are uh
you guys I'll be honest I watched
oh my God that makes sense not not an
actual elf um yeah they're definitely
setting things up right it's like all
these people gotta learn to get along if
they're gonna fight off the evil and
evil is I think that's kind of the theme
of this show right you're you're worried
about your struggles uh between
different species different races but
what's most important is the evil that's
Brewing right underneath you who doesn't
care they don't care what you are
they're gonna defeat you yeah they're
gonna take you out uh we also you know
go uh Galadriel got a little clue into
the little symbol she's been looking for
it's not it's not a word it's a map it's
a plan it's a plan in case I'm killed uh
and my plan is is coming to fruition now
let's do a little bit because we have
our two fantasy shows they're very
different
um let's go through a little which which
you like which one's doing it better
okay we had two ships in these two
episodes we saw the boat uh that
rhaenyra was on and we saw the boat uh
that the the fleet of numenor has you
which one which ship do you like better
I'm not trying to be this person I know
that you just said the new minor ship
which also I'm gonna choose because the
numinar ship we forget that she was uh
when the hurricane or the wind and
everything happened they had to make
ship shift yeah ship makeshift ship so
I'm gonna give them a bonus point for
that so I'm gonna say oh you like their
little mix
pulling ropes on it like I don't know if
it does anything you're a little like I
watch Moana and I don't think this is
correct I don't think that's how that
works I don't think that's how it works
yeah I think their ships are cooler but
also because we've seen the ships from
um uh House of the Dragon too yeah it's
nothing it's nothing special it's cool I
kind of like the big front on the
Targaryen shape I like the new one I
like because they're imagine the
Icebreaker but there's no ice it matches
it sort of matches their armor and also
it's like this we're gonna get a bunch
of more different ships I think in uh
houses or not House of dragon um rings
of power versus a lot a lot more style
to it
um
which food did you like better this
episode uh we saw Hall branding in some
clams that was awesome we got some good
spreads uh in House of the Dragon this
week uh oh we got the yeah when Ray Mira
uh and Damon were kind of just talking
in the garden and there's like a whole
Buffet just laid out yeah
we saw a little cake she ate a little
like citrus and ring of power we got
snails we well this week we got the
clams uh oh yeah
oh I forgot that okay you guys we have
to watch all these shows and so they
kind of blend with me sometimes and I
forgot that fight scene is so fun it's I
love him uh so yes I like that the clams
look good yeah he he's clearly like some
sort of royalty that's kind of hiding
away which is a very interesting reveal
he's a good little thief he's a good
little fighter and he's maybe a little
secret King hiding away I'm two out of
three for rings of power right now I
mean it is some fun fantasy which would
you rather have would you rather have a
work or a direwolf
direwolf is is is more common looking
you could take it to the the outdoor
camera the work was that little dog
thing they fought uh yeah at the org
Camp I like that you like that
I liked it I like the creatures in uh
rings of power so much oh okay they're
so fun well I mean yeah I mean it's Lord
of the Rings so they have more room to
be like let's get really like mythical
yes uh versus I did I did really uh feel
bad for around you this episode when
he's like I'll chop down the tree uh
because those elves they really like the
trees you know his armor is like wood
they respect wood do you respect wood he
does I mean he feels bad he's gotta chop
down that screen Jessica I mean I
respect wood
um this episode of hassle of the Dragons
was too horny for Justin it was I had to
turn it off for 10 minutes
it's like a cold shower instead of this
too much no but um okay so that scene
yeah I get it maybe I'm just not like a
Captain Planet person I'm not like that
in the trees you know I understand the
elves were like when I say I'm in I'm
into ours in real life I mean in the
show I was like dude your boys are dying
you better go chop down but like that
you know they live for a long time and
they're they plant the the seeds and
they see the tree they're there for the
whole life of the tree so it means a lot
to them whereas like we saw this week
with gladrow when she shows up in the
city and she was like oh it didn't look
like this 20 years ago it's like yeah
lady stuff moves on well you're gone for
like a blink of my eye and like a lot of
things change this is the part that I do
hate about the elves is that they ate
they're forever old so it's like to them
they don't care and that's what we got
when they saw the um the dwarves or yeah
when they were like 20 years you missed
everything for me that's a lot for me
that's nothing for you you're right
Jessica you're changing my mind I hate
these elves I didn't mean it like that I
meant more so than I was like they don't
recognize that time works differently
for everyone else so when he was like
chopping down that tree I was like the
tree is old but not as old as their
friend that just got his yeah
I cut his throat he's dying in the
Orchard and he was alive forever and he
would have been alive much longer so
please avenge him by cutting down this
damn tree avenge it's not an end it
wasn't moving yeah yeah it's not an ant
and I love the ends if it was an end I'd
be like dude never mind let him kill
everybody my aunt boy down uh okay uh
that's enough Talking Tom King let's do
our power rankings for the weekend 60
Minutes on the other show
House of the Dragon who's up this week
in power on House of the Dragon who do
you think gained the most power this
week
um I'm gonna say Valerian Corliss chorus
Valerian ooh not even in the episode
yeah right he's gonna be very happy with
people that are in the episode no I like
not only are they now just getting
married in they
co-killed the uh the crab feeder guy uh
they're just on right on the stepson and
then the daughter's getting married to
someone else they're they're fine
they're good to go oh yeah that's right
you know we we heard that uh the
daughter lyanna is being married off to
someone from braavos of the free cities
and so like a partnership with the
valerians and the free cities is very
problematic so the council's like you
gotta fix this problem with your own
marriage uh so yeah Corliss I think
that's a great move he's riding high I
would also say for the first time ever
on talking dragons
viserys is up this week I think he
gained a lot of power this week my boy
is weak he's falling apart he's in a
Loveless marriage but here's the deal oh
yeah please kick down Damon and he
kicked out Otto and I think those were
both two strong moves and it makes him
look powerful for once sure it makes him
look a little powerful I think kicking
out Damon is like you've done this twice
before I nobody told me once at this
time he's serious
okay I mean Corliss was he probably I
think kicking out Otto was a big thing
yeah that is a huge thing the hands what
we know from Game of Thrones the hands
don't get respected no they don't okay
it is tough out there for a hand of the
king I would never want to be the hand
of the king I'd Rather Be The King and I
don't want to be yeah the king's a bad
position too uh do you wanna do you want
to make a pick for rings of power who
gained the most power this week on the
rings of power I'll tell you mine who's
yours it's Anna dar it's Sauron
basically he's doing oh yeah he's doing
great these idiots can't get their [ __ ]
together and he's gonna run this place
easy that's that's easy that's easy
well that's hard because I don't think
it's Gala Trail
you don't think she got the most power
no because she's like also
hunted by the queen
right now because her dad is the king
yeah it's been locked up inside she's
she's putting together a little army
though she's getting a little bit of
power she's getting a little bit of
rings of power but it's like not enough
and it's just her by herself right now
well she's got the captain he's not he's
into it and then I would say Ellen
um Ellen Drew Ellen Drew but I remember
what happens with his son in the future
so I don't really
Who's down this week who lost the most
power on House of the Dragon this week
not renera not renera not right oh well
Otto
Otto Otto's pretty town I don't I know
it was right now and he's pretty down
yeah he got hit he got he got knocked
off he got knocked off he lost he lost
the hand if it wasn't he still got a
grandson possibly in line for the throne
if he didn't loot but he he was the he's
the matriarch of the family yeah he's
the one and so he lost his one position
if he didn't lose his position I'd say
it's a Christian Cole we did oh okay he
is down on power this week he's my boy's
sweating he's sweating it's literally
easy for him to lose everything my voice
going home at night taking 30 minutes to
get all his armor off being like okay
what can I do to avoid her tomorrow but
also watch her uh did she drink the Moon
too please tell me
I love her so much but I hate her at the
same time oh my God this girl get me in
trouble
oh oh give me some trouble uh uh yeah
he's pretty down this week I think I
think I agree with you though that Otto
Otto is pretty down this way I mean my
boy Damon he might be down again
he took a hit this week
Placer thing he was still he was just
emotional and everyone like a chess
board he gets he gets a bad hangover he
gets kind of he's got to pay for the
hotel room for his ex you know what I
mean she said pay on your way out pay on
your way out he said what do you call
her he was like I'm not common anymore
the not so common [ __ ] I was like
you're talking a lot for a man that's
asleep a white worm now she's she's
trading secrets she knows how important
that is go off girl she's doing good
honestly she's up
what about rings of power who do you
think lost the most power this week oh
uh all of the anyone who's not an orc
basically lost the most power I mean
Iran deer really took a big hit this
week yeah some good fight put up a good
fight but man
got two of his brothers killed that
wasn't good I mean wow
oh humans in the town are like what are
these elves up to this is a bad idea
oh I love him so much I don't want to
say he's down he's down I'm sorry he's
looking good but he's he's down he's
down poor baby yeah I get I agree I'll
agree he did get he did get his voice
basically anyone who's not an orc is
down bad this week on rings of power not
looking good for them uh not looking
good uh for for Middle Earth uh but
that's it for this episode of big
question presents talking dragons uh be
sure to check us out right here each and
every week we're breaking down the shows
uh right here on new rock stars Spitting
Fire with the targaryens discussing
rings of Power with the humans and The
Elves and the dwarves and the hard foots
and the Orcs And all of them can't get
along uh don't forget to check out our
mini great merch options over at New
rockstarsmerch.com pick up that latest
Obsession shirt uh uh Eric's breakdown
of the episode of will be up tomorrow on
the channel so be sure to check that out
uh and stick around for all the awesome
fantasy action that's going on yeah here
on new rockstars follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clemons follow me at granted
Barrick and just make sure you subscribe
to new rockstars wherever you get your
podcast or watch the show uh subscribe
to big question do it all baby uh have a
great rest of your week thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week
right here on talking dragons goodbye
Drew Kenny
[Music]